To get the most out of what's set to be one
of the biggest, most unmissable blockbusters
of the summer and possibly the year, we've
rounded up the tidbits and plot details you'll
want to brush up on.
Here's everything you need to know before
you see Fast and Furious Presents: Hobbs and
Shaw.
When the character is first introduced in
Fast Five, Johnson's Agent Luke Hobbs is a
straitlaced do-gooder in the Diplomatic Security
Service.
As a result, he spends the majority of that
movie tracking down Vin Diesel's Dominic Toretto
in a bid to stop Dom and his crew from pulling
off the most outlandish heist Rio has ever
seen.
But it's not long before Hobbs grudgingly
sees the good in the gang, and decides to
work with them.
The vault of money they're heisting belongs
to drug lord Hernan Reyes, who is so peeved
about his profits getting plundered that he
kills Hobbs' entire team and attempts to frame
Toretto and his gang for the hit.
But Hobbs is smarter than the average beefcake
and collaborates with the Fast crew to get
even with Reyes.
Fast Five marked the beginning of a fruitful
relationship between Hobbs and Toretto's gang,
with Hobbs growing to understand the complicated
gray area between being a good guy and a bad
guy.
Here's where the soap opera leanings of the
Fast and Furious franchise really start going
into overdrive.
When Hobbs returns in Fast and Furious 6,
he teams up with the gang again to take down
terrorist Owen Shaw.
Shaw ends up in a coma after his battle with
the Fast Family, but there's also a twist
ending which introduces Jason Statham as Owen's
brother, Deckard Shaw.
A post-credits scene reveals that he was behind
team member Han's death in The Fast and Furious:
Tokyo Drift.
Although Tokyo Drift is the third film of
the franchise, it takes place between the
events of Fast & Furious 6 and Furious 7.
Deckard continues as the baddie in Furious
7, but he's grudgingly forced to make nice
with the Fast gang to get even with the big
bad in Fate of the Furious.
Still, even by the end of the film, Shaw is
pretty clear about the fact that none of his
baby-saving action scenes made him a willing
member of Toretto's "family."
"I can't believe you went to see my mother."
That makes him the perfect foil for Hobbs.
One of the biggest reasons Hobbs and Shaw
have such an entertaining dynamic is that
they have complementary character arcs within
the series.
While Hobbs has realized that he sometimes
has to break a few laws and collaborate with
criminals to save the day, Shaw has discovered
that he sometimes needs the help of good guys
to carry out his dirty deeds.
Their conflicting sets of morals and goals
has given them one of the most fascinating
and hilarious relationships in the franchise.
As highlighted by the prison break scene from
the Fate of the Furious, these two rivals
are often forced to fight alongside each other
while also fighting against each other.
Speaking to IGN, director David Leitch has
copped to the fact that Hobbs and Shaw was
influenced by the buddy cop movies he grew
up loving:
"There's these buddy movies from the '80s
and '90s like Lethal Weapon and 48 Hours that
really speak to me as a filmmaker."
If you've caught even just five minutes of
a Fast and Furious movie, then you already
know just how important family is to the franchise.
"I don't have friends.
I got family."
Not only is it Toretto's favorite word and
motive for committing crimes, but those family
values also provide the backbone for much
of the franchise's major plots.
Hobbs and Shaw looks to be extending these
values from the franchise to the spinoff,
too.
Not only is noted Fast and Furious superfan
Helen Mirren returning to play Shaw's rough-and-ready
mother, but his sister, played by Vanessa
Kirby, is also showing up as a main character.
Hattie Shaw, an MI-5 agent, looks to be bringing
some serious trouble in Hobbs and Shaw's direction.
She'll be appealing to Shaw's loyalty to family
and Hobbs' loyalty to saving the world in
taking down Idris Elba's villainous Brixton.
But it isn't just Shaw's brood that'll be
a major part of the movie.
Though we haven't seen much of Hobbs' family
in the franchise so far, it looks as though
Hobbs and Shaw will be introducing audiences
to Hobbs' full Samoan family.
The most recent trailer for the movie teases
a massive set piece involving Hobbs' family,
who look like they'll be putting their traditional
fighting skills to good use in helping their
brother defeat Brixton's endless squad of
bad guys.
Interestingly, the family connection doesn't
end there: Johnson's cousin, WWE wrestler
Roman Reigns, will be swinging a sledgehammer
of family justice as Hobbs' brother.
Speaking to Empire, Leitch has teased great
things for the battle sequence, particularly
for fans of a good old-fashioned smackdown.
"Roman Reigns and Dwayne teaming up as sort
of a tag team against a couple of mercenaries
is pretty awesome.
It's going to be a huge treat for wrestling
fans."
Bringing a new villainous dimension to the
Fast and Furious franchise, and adding to
the already stellar roster of actors in the
series, is Idris Elba as Brixton.
The self-proclaimed "black Superman" looks
to be one of the most powerful foes Hobbs
and Shaw have encountered thus far.
"Damn.
He really is black Superman."
Described in the official plot description
as a "cyber-genetically enhanced anarchist,"
Brixton is a supervillain who appears to be
abusing technology to make himself harder,
bigger, faster, stronger.
Oh, and it looks like he's bulletproof to
boot.
With trailers for Hobbs and Shaw showing the
villain using technology to bulk up and hulk
out while also threatening the world with
an insidious bio-threat, Brixton promises
to be a next-level heavy.
Asked by Collider whether he wanted to build
a whole new world of characters for Hobbs
and Shaw or borrow some familiar faces from
the franchise, Leitch sounds like he's open
to the idea of cameos:
"I think it' be fun to nod and have a couple
of the characters come by and make their appearances.
But I think we have a really strong point
of view that we want to create our own characters
for this world."
That certainly sounds like the answer of a
man holding his cards close to the vest, as
he should be.
Surprise cameos of this nature always work
best when they're at their most unexpected.
Still, we perhaps shouldn't rule out a brief
surprise appearance from beloved characters
like Ludacris' Tej Parker or Tyrese Gibson's
Roman Pearce.
However, the greatest and most unexpected
cameo may come from someone outside the existing
Fast family.
Keanu Reeves was rumored to make an appearance
in the film, but unfortunately The Rock himself
shot down that much-anticipated cameo in a
conversation with MTV News, saying:
"I will confirm that he's not in it, by the
way.
That rumor just started to kind of swell.
But I will tell you this, we do have some
surprises coming."
Just what those surprises could be is anyone's
guess.
Could it be the return of Han?
A surprise casting for a Shaw patriarch?
Or could The Rock just be blowing a smokescreen
to make the Keanu cameo hit even harder?
Don't get your hopes up for a cameo appearance
from Vin Diesel in Hobbs and Shaw, though,
not even at the traditional post-action barbecue.
Not only is Hobbs and Shaw looking to establish
its own cinematic universe without Toretto,
but there's still the alleged beef between
Diesel and Johnson to deal with.
That beef surfaced in August 2016 during the
last week of filming Fate of the Furious,
when Johnson published a cryptic Instagram
post which implied that an anonymous co-star
wasn't conducting himself as a, quote, "true
professional" and that fans could see his
blood, quote, "legit boiling" in some scenes.
The feud seemed to drag on for months under
the guise of vague social media back-and-forths,
with Michelle Rodriguez even confirming it
to People:
“They’re ‘bros,’ man.
They’re friends, and ultimately even friends
reach a point where they have to set aside
their differences to make a movie for multicultural
people around the world, and that is the bigger
scheme of things.”
The two have since reportedly buried the hatchet,
with Johnson telling Entertainment Tonight
that he and Diesel are simply different people:
"Just like, in life, you have different philosophies
and people have different fundamental philosophies
on how you do things."
Meanwhile, Diesel said of his co-star:
"We still love each other.
That's my boy."
The Fast and Furious franchise has built a
reputation for itself as one of the boldest,
most ridiculous, and bombastic action film
series ever made.
With Leitch directing Hobbs and Shaw and regular
Fast and Furious writer Chris Morgan behind
the screenplay, the spinoff looks as though
it's in capable hands for maintaining that
reputation.
Not only did Morgan pen the first film, he's
also the man behind the genius resurgence
of the franchise from Fast Five onwards.
He's the writer who looked at the ludicrously
giant action sequences already delivered by
the franchise and said, "No, let's go bigger."
"Start out stealing DVD players in East LA
and ends up stealing 100 million dollars in
Rio."
"Not bad, huh?"
Meanwhile, Leitch might be one of Hollywood's
most highly sought after and respected action
directors.
The former stuntman directed Atomic Blonde
and Deadpool 2 and co-directed the first John
Wick.
He's the perfect director to bring into the
franchise at this moment, and he's sure to
put his own frenetic, sardonic spin on the
series with Hobbs and Shaw.
As you're probably well aware from having
watched and rewatched the trailers for Hobbs
and Shaw with your mouth swinging open in
awe, we've already seen a lot of action.
But for those afraid that the promo clips
have given away the movie's best set pieces,
Chris Morgan is here to set those fears at
ease, telling Empire that there's more to
come:
"We have so much that we're holding back.
This is a blink of the action in the film.
A blink.”
It's a gutsy claim to make, but a believable
one.
After all, if you compare the trailers that
were released for Fate of the Furious with
the actual film, it's easy to see how the
promos barely scratched the surface.
With so much action and story to tell, there's
also a fair chance that Hobbs and Shaw could
share a similar running time to Fate of the
Furious, which gave audiences an epic, 150-minute
cinematic ride.
If you're giddy at the prospect of Hobbs and
Shaw enjoying their own series of films rather
than just one standalone spinoff, you're in
luck.
Leitch has confirmed that Hobbs and Shaw is
intended as the first movie of an ongoing
franchise.
The director told Collider:
"We're starting a franchise.
So we want it to be a little bit more grounded,
it's a little bit more character-centric.
We're going to set up the stakes for these
guys and their relationship."
If that sounds a little slow for a Fast & Furious
movie, you've got nothing to worry about.
"We're also going to have some great set pieces
and some action that you'd expect from that
type of franchise, you know, it's something
that opens in summer."
Awesome though that may be, there is a downside:
It means that Hobbs and Shaw probably won't
be starring in Fast and Furious 9 while their
own respective franchise gets going.
The long-running Fast and Furious franchise
could be coming to an end after the next couple
of films, but it seems as though the saga's
creative team is already putting plans in
place to keep the series alive in new and
exciting ways.
Hobbs and Shaw is the first of many planned
Fast and Furious spinoffs.
On top of a theme park ride, Diesel has also
teased that a Fast and Furious movie with
a woman in the lead may be coming soon.
In an Instagram post shared at the beginning
of 2019, Diesel revealed that he and producer
Samantha Vincent had heard a pitch at Universal
for just such a movie.
Judging by his Instagram caption, it sounds
like it went well:
"There are three new spin offs that we have
promised Universal…this week we heard a
pitch for the Fast female protagonist driven
spinoff I created in 2017, and you can tell
by the smile on Samantha's face it was VERY
exciting."
In the meantime, we'll just have to live like
Dom:
"I live my life a quarter-mile at a time."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Fast
& Furious are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.